but lead has had a very long history it
was one of the first metals to be widely
used the the Romans used this for
drinking materials they also laid
acetate that's the compound of lead and
vinegar is meant to taste sweet and the
Romans added this to their wine to make
it sweeter the fact that it was really
very poisonous and caused possibly even
calls madness was not really widely
recognized in fact some people have
suggested that part of the collapse of
the Roman Empire was due to too much
late lead was very widely used in the UK
for water pipes because it's easy to
manufacture and to join together it
tends not to have been very dangerous in
terms of drinking water because it gets
a coating on the surface so you do not
get much laid in the water though if you
do have a house with lead pipes and it
is usually advisable to change them it's
again it was used very widely from the
1920s up till the late 70s or 80s as an
additive for petrol in the old days when
petrol engines were first introduced
when you came to a hill and put down the
accelerate of your car the engine
started misfiring so called pinking and
the whole thing shook so it was really
quite difficult to drive up hills but
then it was discovered that you could
put in a compound circle tetraethyl and
which was really very poisonous but the
guy who discovered it washed his hands
in public at a press conference saying
look it's so safe despite the fact that
there were people dying in his factory
so it was very widely adopted and so it
was only in quite recent times that it
was realised how much lead was being
blown out in
the atmosphere and car exhausts and so
it's now we have almost everywhere we
have led lead-free petrol as a result of
people realising the poisonous of lead